breaking the ice a thorny issue
life's rich tapestry our everyday speech
is littered with metaphors see what we
did there
or as the poet paul muldoon put it the
impulse to find the likeness between
unlike things
is very basic to us but metaphors aren't
just for poets
they shape our beliefs attitudes and
actions in ways we don't even realize
so what exactly is a metaphor at its
simplest
a metaphor is x equals y sometimes it's
stated explicitly
every day is a winding road but more
often metaphors are harder to unpick
take the end of the great gatsby we beat
on boats against the current
borne back ceaselessly into the past on
first glance
we're talking about rowers fighting the
pool of the current but the image is
mixed up with time
the past the power of nostalgia many
think the best metaphors bring
colour and meaning to the everyday
author james geary says that
by mixing the foreign with the familiar
the marvelous with the mundane
metaphors make the world sting and
tingle but not everyone is a fan
philosopher thomas hobbes compared the
use of metaphors to
wandering amongst innumerable
absurdities which is of course
a metaphor if we're trying to express
anything abstract
metaphors are hard to avoid take
heartbreak imagine your friend is going
through a breakup
they're probably a complete mess beside
themselves
consumed by jealousy or perhaps they're
bottling up their feelings
some metaphors have become so familiar
they almost feel literal
think about time again there's the tired
old metaphor time is money
i hope you spend today profitably thanks
for being so
generous with your time what does it say
about our society that we equate
time and money like this but dig a
little deeper and you'll see even the
way we think about time is metaphorical
we move
through it travellers on a path with the
future up ahead and the past behind us
the american linguist george lakov
called these orientational metaphors
take the idea of up and down he's at the
peak of health
he fell ill she's on top of the
situation he's under my control
she was able to rise above her emotions
he dragged the conversation down to his
level
lakov also helped develop the idea of
political framing
the words we choose affect how we
perceive and deal with social issues
and help decide what becomes publicly
accepted common sense
and metaphors play a huge role in that
we often talk about the battle
or fight against cancer but a 2019 study
suggests military metaphors like this
could actually undermine cancer
treatment
make people feel fatalistic about their
chances and even put implicit blame on
those who don't survive
crime is another area full of metaphor
we have
crime waves the criminal underworld
crimes committed in cold blood
but what effect might metaphors really
have in 2011
a stanford study gave one group a
pamphlet describing crime as a wild
beast preying upon a city a second group
were given a different pamphlet
describing crime as a virus
plaguing the population when asked how
to tackle the issue
the first group were 20 more likely to
endorse stricter policing than the
second
so the metaphors we choose matter not
just for our beliefs but potentially for
our laws
our politics and our treatment of each
other lakoff and his co-author mark
johnson put it like this
the people who get to impose their
metaphors in the culture
get to define what we consider to be
true or to adapt a well-known example
knowledge of metaphors is power